in June and July st. isaac's cathedral
and the peter and paul fortress are lit
up in the evening with a special light
naturally it never gets dark during the
summer white knights among the countless
sights on view day and night is yusupov
palace on the mica river famously linked
with the murder of Rasputin local
photographer Dmitry Conrad often finds
interesting unconventional angles by or
on the city's waterways some of his
pictures are on display in the
prestigious Russian Museum my teeth I
look for color compositions I look for
moments when the city becomes a painting
blue Chicago girls kissing or like a
painting what I look for fragments
Justinian food for a community to 300
bridges spanning the city's canals of
earn st. Petersburg the nickname Venice
of the north and right by the river neva
is one of the city's best-known
landmarks the hermitage museum complex
also including the old winter palace of
bazaars Dmitry Conrad discovers new
details here all the time he takes
inspiration from both the majestic
baroque architecture and the
comprehensive art collections inside
yeah that's dope I'm glad that the
Hermitage is in my hometown it's one of
the biggest museums in the country in
the world even a lot of people from st.
Petersburg like me go there to not just
tourists
among the 65,000 works on display here
are paintings by Matisse Picasso and
Kandinsky
Renaissance masters such as Leonardo da
Vinci can be marveled at here as well
the world famous collection was founded
by empress catherine the great back in
1764 although originally not for the
public outside the city is the former
summer residence of his arse peterhof
palace together with central st.
Petersburg it forms a UN cultural
heritage site Peter the Great had the
complex built here by the Baltic Sea in
the early 18th century you can see that
there's um they they have put a lot of
effort to keep it like like the old days
you could say I think he's fantastic
have you here for 20 years ago and I
didn't remember really I think I was
here during winter it's perfect
beautiful most of the 5 million tourists
each year come during the summer the
famous fountains turned on from May
through October are powered by gravity
alone Peter the Great planned this feat
of landscape engineering in the early
18th century the 150 fountains pump
almost a thousand liters of water per
second into the air that's why Pater
hope is sometimes described as the
capital of fountains at the water this
covers a lot of fountains are the pride
of our country for the Sun laughs and I
tried of our Tsar Peter the Great the
man who created this thing of beauty for
us and for all our visitors yellow okay
but a cool couple
it's still perfectly bright when we
return to the city in the evening the
Sun reflects on the Church of the
saviour on spilled blood the white
knights might be bright but temperatures
still drop to around 10 degrees Celsius
we find local folk group oppa
entertaining passers-by along the
riverbank and what better way to keep
warm in these cool conditions then by
dancing along for locals like Dimitri
the White Nights will never lose their
magic it feels strange it's time to go
to bed but it's still light people
should be at home but everyone's out on
the streets and there's plenty to stay
awake for way after midnight you can see
the bridges opening for taller ships
and so the day comes to a close or is it
just the beginning
you